after falling COBIT 19 cases are spiking
again in some regions and the fears of a
second wave are real the list of
authorities around the world reimposing
coronavirus linked to lockdowns
is growing California has banned going
to bars and eating inside in restaurants
South African authorities have reimpose
de curfew and an alcohol ban with no
vaccine millions across the world faced
similar prospects if Coe bid 19 cases
continue to grow welcome to you Kovac 19
special on DWI Monica Jones in Berlin
good to have you with us so experts have
been warning of a second wave saying it
would most likely hit in winter but as
we know by now Tsar's Cove 2 is full of
surprises Israel managed the first wave
really well but only weeks later the
country is struggling with a new
coronavirus outbreak case numbers hit
record highs this week the new normal
first register your personal details and
take a temperature check before you can
enter a cafe in Jerusalem students are
on Livni is for 8 that the number of
coronavirus cases is once again rising
sharply she lost her part-time job
during the lockdown in March and April
now she's facing renewed uncertainty I'm
afraid of the health issues and the
economic situation students are getting
infected people my age it's not only the
over-60s so it's frightening and
financially I'm still unemployed I still
have to pay my rent and
kolima Mandira early on ezra closed its
borders and imposed a strict lockdown
for several weeks at a cost
unemployment rose from four to more than
20% but schools and businesses started
to reopen in May a few weeks ago it
looked like Israel navigated its way
quite well through the corona pandemic
that has changed dramatically special
Corona wards and hospitals and
drive-through testing centers like this
one had to be reopened these testing
stations had closed because there was no
demand
now cars are lining up again experts are
discussing what went wrong there were no
strategic preparation what will happen
after the lockdown and what we've seen
now is the second wave here Israel is a
result of the inaction during the first
wave and it's unfortunate because we're
one of the few countries which ended the
first wave with 300 deaths
few infections and we could have revived
the economy very well Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu was widely praised
for his handling of the crisis first
time around that has changed people are
worried about a second wave new
restrictions were announced this week
including increasing fines for not
wearing masks limiting the number of
people in public areas and restaurants
it feels like a deja vu for chef Daniel
Ovitz who had just reopened this fish
restaurant in Tel Aviv you don't know if
you're gonna work tomorrow or not last
time it happened it was very
surprising this time we were more ready
for that but still the uncertainty it's
very confusing
another prolonged lockdown might still
be on the cards a dismal prospect for
most Israelis who thought the worst was
already over and Israelis aren't alone
of course that threat is omnipresent how
do we deal with that Stephen Taylor is
professor and clinical psychologist in
the department of psychiatry at the
University of British Columbia in
Vancouver and is also the author of the
psychology of pandemics preparing for
the next global outbreak of infectious
diseases it's so good to have you with
us let me start by asking you how do you
cope with the pandemic well it's
important to set a structure for
yourself and to set realistic
expectations so we know this pandemic
will be eventually over we don't know
when but you just try and keep on with
your life as normally as you possibly
can so but some people find that very
difficult what would you say is worse
for our psyche in such a situation
having to deal with an invisible but
potentially lethal virus or having to
give up our social habits well it
depends on the person some people have
no problem giving up this the social
habits they're quite happy to to sit at
home other people find it very difficult
so it's very much differs from person to
person people are experiencing this
pandemic in different ways for some
people the biggest concern of the
socio-economic impacts like not having a
job for other people who might have
pre-existing medical conditions the
biggest concerns are their physical
health what advice could you Babs give
those who will really find it difficult
to deal with it well they need to reach
out I mean for a start you could reach
out to friends and family and connect
with those individuals if that doesn't
work there are Internet resources where
you can go online and get help for
anxiety related problems so those sorts
of things it's important to do sorts of
planning there are a lot of resources
out there but people need to to go out
and look for them and well how big a
role does our psyche have in actually
spreading the virus are we actually
contributing to
spreading the virus well a virus has
spread it depends on what people do or
choose not to do if the lockdown ends
and we go out to pubs and parks and
beaches and and congregate together that
is going to contribute to the the the
arrival of the next wave so we need to
consider our behavior that plays a vital
role in the spreading and containment of
of infection a professor Taylor and our
report we heard because you touched
touched upon something out behavior in
this report we heard that Israel hadn't
prepared for the time after the lockdown
so what lessons can be learned what what
could or should we do that at least we
can prevent - the second way for deal
with it better well we need to
understand from a start it's very
difficult to predict how things will
unfold there are a lot of uncertainties
and what's going to make it easier for
people who have to go into a second
lockdown if health authorities can use
the modeling or the use of lessons
they've learned from the first lockdown
to try and predict how long the second
lockdown will last that's going to help
people cope if people are told ok you've
got to be in lockdown for say six weeks
that's gonna be a lot easier for them to
deal with and if they didn't know how
long they're gonna be and so making this
whole experience more predictable more
controllable it's going to ease the
stress on people and therefore make it
easier for them to comply with lockdown
all right professor Steven Taylor
they're from the department of
psychiatry at the University of British
Columbia it's certainly learning by
doing thank you so much for your
expertise and your time thanks very much
well I'm sure you have many many more
questions and - now is the time for some
more of those our science correspondent
Derek Williams stands by and ready to
give some answers can a mother who is
asymptomatic breastfeed it must be
terrifying for the mother of an infant
to test positive for a cove at 19
whether she displays symptoms or or not
because the relationship is such an
intimate one physically that it seems
highly unlikely that the baby won't
contract the disease as well despite the
threat though both the w-h-o and most
national health authorities urge mothers
who have tested positive for the disease
whether they're symptomatic or not to
continue to breastfeed because the
benefits of breastfeeding and
skin-to-skin contact between mother and
child substantially outweigh any risks
associated with kovat 19 for the child
so it still isn't a hundred percent
certain that that breast milk always
remains completely free from the virus
but but the evidence indicates that it's
not really spread that way mothers who
test positive should however follow a
list of precautions to try to prevent
passing the virus along to their baby if
this is an issue for you I recommend
really taking the time to read the much
more extensive information posted on the
w-h-o and and CDC websites it can
actually help calm your fears especially
to learn that most newborns and infants
who get kovat 19 have mild or no
symptoms and will eventually as far as
we can tell recover fully so why do most
infected newborns recover easily
we aren't certain why there are so few
reports of babies with severe cases of
kovat 19 because that isn't the case
with other respiratory diseases like
like influenza for example but there are
several hypotheses it could be that
differences between the infant immune
system and the adult immune system are
playing a role babies have higher
numbers of some virus killing immune
cells than adults have infant immune
systems are also less likely to plunge
into into dangerous cytokine storms and
and and and don't forget the kids are
not yet saddled with all this sort of
baggage of comorbidities that we acquire
in the course of our lives things like
like heart disease and diabetes a more
contested school of thought says that
because babies have fewer ace 2
receptors which are those receptors that
the virus uses to get into the cell that
that's having an effect on disease
severity but whatever's causing the
phenomenon it's it's really not the
first time that we've seen it in
connection with a corona virus some
children were also less affected during
the SARS and an MERS epidemics and you
can post your questions to Derek on our
YouTube channel if you'd like to keep up
with the latest developments on the
corona virus do subscribe to our
newsletter just log on to DW calm corona
- newsletter a second way for no
second-wave staying safe is a good
policy in any case now one couple in
Brazil is doing so in style once they
get their spacesuits on they're ready to
take on the world
tercio gal Dino and Alicia Lim are both
in their mid sixties and two are in
high-risk groups they hope to send a
message with their gear that everyone
must protect themselves especially in
countries hard-hit
by the coronavirus like Brazil
you